spies and guns and jason statham it's
almost like we've seen this before a lot
[Music]
Killer Elite now Killer Elite is pretty
simple yet a lot happens in it it takes
place in the 80s Jason Statham is like
alright I'm done you know killing people
any here later someone kidnaps one of
his friends and they're like alright we
need you to kill these three people
because we hate them so Statham's like
those sausages Charlie actually didn't
say that but you know he pretty much
agrees anything he kills people and then
Clive Owens hot on his trail it's like
alright I'm a guy who kills people also
and he's killing people that we like so
we're gonna go after him and then you
know you got your movies I supposedly
killer elites based on like a true story
it's based on a book I don't know if
it's really based on a true story I
don't know if it happened how it
happened in this movie because if you
look into it every website that you find
saying it is true you find another one
saying it's all [ __ ] so I don't know
and the actors in this movie they're
really good I mean Robert De Niro's in
it Jason Statham's in it Clive Owen I've
always liked those guys with Clive Owen
especially the first time I saw Clive
Owen I was like that dudes a badass and
he became like you know Biggs Angelina
Jolie movie where she steps on a mines
all I remember about the movie but I
remember he was awesome so I guess I
remember two things about the movie some
of the characters were good the others
you don't care about you're like alright
this is just how people die it almost
feels like going into this movie I
should have gotten like a page of
character BIOS that I didn't get like
when you buy your ticket for this movie
you should get a page or just all the
characters and their BIOS what they do
where they works like oh this was Clive
Owens character he worked here now he
works here he does this because of this
so you at least know a bit about him you
know like Batman Arkham Asylum had where
it's like oh this is Edward nygma he
does this and this and this and you're
like okay I already knew that but okay
it's good to have the bio and there are
some mustaches in here let me tell you
these mustaches put chat to shame
straight-up 80s mustaches it was quite
awesome now like I said a lot happens in
this movie a lot so much of fact that
almost seems like disjointed noir
happens in Killer Elite the movies that
I've seen that are like twice the length
of Killer Elite and Killer elites just a
two hour movie you know Apollo 13 were
they're like alright we need this to fit
into this using nothing but that it's
almost like that was like the writer and
director were like all right we need all
these events to happen in a movie that's
just two hours long at a point in this
movie I'll say alright it's coming to
the end of the movie I know because a
lot of stuff has happened people are
dead it's wow there's an hour left in
the movie like I said the acting is
really good in the movie I like the
action the movie 2 is actually really
exciting no shootouts Jason Statham
fighting Clive Owen
throw down your like alright awesome a
big bees nest underground how is that
not cool and kind of terrifying because
I'd haul ass I'd be like no I'm out bees
uh-huh I saw Honey I Shrunk the kids it
never ends well this movie just wasn't
locked down you know it was a little
rough around the edges it just wasn't
put together as well as I wanted it to
be it's almost like if they come out
with a sci-fi movie that's just okay but
you just think to yourself you're like
oh that's alright but I do have
Battlestar Galactica and Firefly and
Star Wars before Vader yelled no I don't
need one that's just okay it's kind of
like killer relief for me there are a
lot of spy movies and hitman movies and
thrillers that are done better than
Killer Elite you got cloak and dagger
from the 80s not really but you know
whatever
in the end I'll say it's okay but you're
not gonna remember it in t-minus one day
I mean with DeNiro and Clive oh and I
just thought it would be better it's not
as good as a De Niro and Clive Owen
movie you know it was really good in the
movie is the sound far be it for me to
be an audiophile or something like that
but the sound was really good when
something blew up you knew it blew up
when a gunshot went off and people
weren't supposed to hear it it went off
you're like someone heard that so I
gotta give it up for the sound the sound
is really good alright so spies
espionage hitmen action guns all the
good stuff what's your favorite movie of
that type comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]